Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 148th episode!
BAU BAU!
148!
We're so close to 150!
Wow, it sounds like maybe we're a bit noisy for the morning No!
It's got to be noisy!
Well, it sounds like maybe today might turn out on the right path But maybe there's some more Mouth fans watching and it's your first time today Yeah
Explain a little bit about what FUWAMOCO Morning is.
Because it needs a lot of explanation.
It does.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday today, Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Japan is tonight on!
In Japan, it's tonight on.
But right now, it's morning!
It's morning if you believe it's morning.
It can always be morning in your heart, I guess.
BAU BAU!
Let's start off a new day!
Let's make it a good one, okay?
And on that note, Moco-chan.
Did we get a submission from a Ruffian?
Maybe that, you know, something was seen somewhere?
I appreciate Ruffians, but...
I don't know.
I like to sing.
Keep the sightings down to a minimum, but I... It's important to know too.
Not Pero again.
I'm sorry.
Where was Pero spotted this time?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
What is this?
Why do I have a bad feeling running down my spine?
The Pero turned into a robot!
A giant one!
This looks like it's a really big one, like we're looking from the top or something.
The name is... Oh, pero.
What does that mean?
That's frightening.
Now we have to find out!
You know, is it here to protect Earth, or...
Bring terror on Aizu?
Wicked!
See, that's what I was thinking, no?
I think it has to be the terror part!
Because you know, why would Pero switch from the nastiness he already spreads to, you know, protecting us, right?
We're doomed!
Don't say that, okay, Ruffians?
Why not?
What should we do to stop this?
Get in the Pero.
No!
Can you imagine the mouth opening, the long tongue rolling out and be like... I was just thinking, if we just get some paint, maybe we can make things better.
Paint?
Yeah, just give it a bit of a facelift.
What?
Just get rid of, you know, the...
I am!
Hi!
BAU BAU!
Morning is nasty!
I think Biboo would.
Oh, Biboo would get the Pero.
No, no, no, no, no.
That just sounds wrong.
I won't even give her a broken microwave.
I'm not gonna make her do that, okay?
It's true.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe, maybe Pero could like fly to the deep depths of the universe and then get lost.
Maybe.
Right.
Let's not think about it for now until we get another sighting.
Sounds good, yeah.
No panic Moria.
No panic, no good.
Yes, yes.
Yes!
Sounds good Moco-chan, thank you.
You're welcome!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I'm not sure if you saw this, but it definitely brought a big smile to our faces!
Yeah!
Maybe it'll make your day a bit brighter!
You know, last year was hololive English's second concert, Breaking Dimension!
Yeah!
Breaking Dimension!
Breaking Dimensions.
Just the other day in the Philippines at the Las Piñas National High School.
It seems like almost the whole school.
The whole school sung and danced with these inventions.
It was quite a moving up ceremony.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Everyone's dancing, you know?
Everybody is in sync!
Right!
Training and everything!
Amazing!
You have to check it out, Ruffians!
They even know the lyrics!
They know more than just the lyrics!
It really really touched us!
You know, we talked about it once before, but the lyrics of a song really mean a lot to us.
They're breaking dimensions very much so.
So we're really glad that, you know, maybe all those feelings that we hold while singing it, that all the students that they hold them too.
Yeah.
I just think about, you know, everybody working together with their friends.
They're like, oh this part, this part, oh I don't have this part.
Right?
What was it here, like the crayon?
Oh, the feet.
Yeah.
You heard that the principal's song is a jailbreak?
Mr. Principal!
Mr. Principal, you're a Ruffian now too, okay?
Mr. Principal, I'm gonna say BAU BAU, okay?
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, that was rude!
Okay!
3, 2, 1.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
You can't do it like this, okay?
But thank you so much for doing your very special ceremony.
And congratulations on reaching for all of your futures.
Every single one of you.
Please look back on it fondly.
BAU BAU!
Hey, no silly Moco-chan.
It wasn't a graduation ceremony, it was a moving up ceremony!
That sounds so cool!
They weren't tired, they sure did!
I wonder how much practice they did all day.
So many questions!
I wanna know!
I was thinking, you know, we all released the shorts.
Right!
I hope this one on just us dancing it.
That would be a lot of shorts if they did it for each student.
I wonder if there's any students that just kept on repeating my video, right?
Oh!
Right!
I was thinking about that.
I hope!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, I'm sure you heard about it.
But just the other day, it was our very beloved Sparkling Rock Biboo's birthday!
Happy birthday!
On the 14th.
She did not turn 14.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
But you know, in true FIWU fashion, nothing gets her down, okay?
So instead for her birthday, she shared some very cute new outfits on the VR chat together with the pebbles.
But it seems like things got very silly.
Yeah, I'm not surprised.
Not surprised at all.
But you know, Biboo, she's been having a lot of fun together with Shiori on VRChat recently.
I hope that we can join that sometime too!
VRChat amazing.
That'd be fun, huh?
Oh, we're gonna teach this VRChat too, okay?
But you know, we can't wait until Biboo's big bash.
Only a little bit longer.
Biboo's big birthday bash.
I did it.
beloved people's big birthday bash.
That was better.
BAU BAU.
A little Mason?
Yes!
Hi!
I love it!
We must make birthday pass, Popo!
Yes!
Wow!
Ruffians!
BAU B
I'm sure that you're all extremely surprised, shocked, and excited by the news.
But, our senpai from hololive English Midgar Club, she announced that she'll be graduating on May 1st.
She just announced it yesterday night.
Yeah, I'm sure you heard the news, but...
You know, it's very hard to say goodbye.
She's been such an influential talent.
You know, member of hololive more than anything and Vtuber too.
And you know, we know it was probably a very hard decision, but we wish her all the best and hope for her happiness.
As we're sure you can imagine, there are a lot of things that we still wanted to do with Gura-senpai, you know?
We want to sing together, dance together, play games together, and even just chat more.
We're really sad to be apart.
And you know?
We know that there's been a lot of sad announcements and departures recently, and it's hard to have to say goodbye to those who mean so much to you, you know?
So, Ruffians, we want you to know it's okay to be sad, to grieve, and maybe even feel a little bit upset too.
But just know that we're here!
And while we know our experiences are very different from others,
Goodbye, rough times here and there too for us.
We're still very happy to be here at hololive English.
And we know there isn't too much time left before we have to say goodbye.
But we hope that we can have a lot of fun time together with you and Senpai too!
And you know, we want to say a big thank you to her for all the amazing moments and the memories that we've had.
All thanks to our very well-loved Senpai.
BAU BAU!
You look so cute!
Thank you Gura!
Thank you Gura-senpai!
So you know, just know that it's okay to feel those feelings, okay?
We understand.
BAU BAU!
We saw you know!
There's another senpai that has some exciting news.
Exciting!
Luna-senpai from hololive Indonesia IG!
She's released an album!
Yes!
Pandora!
And did you hear?
It's not just an album.
It also has physical copies!
Yes!
So you know, that means, you know, instead of just being like, oh, I can listen to lots of YouTube or Spotify or whatever.
Of course you can do that.
It means you can put your paws on it!
You can hold the CD!
Oh no, senpai.
This is her voice on this disc.
On her new album, it has 10 songs.
And, uh, it's important.
This is an important part.
So, uh, pre-orders closed.
Tomorrow?
April 17th at 6pm JST.
Very, very soon.
Very soon.
In a few hours.
The only time that you can get your paws on the maze.
Yes.
Maze.
Because the physical release.
Now, this is important.
It's completely made to order!
So if you want one, then you need to pre-order it.
There's a bunch of bonuses too!
Like a handwritten autograph, and even an online meet-and-greet application ticket!
Did you hear about the online meet-and-greet application ticket?
Moona, Moona wrote on this.
You can also chat with her and be like, I have this and you know your hands touch this.
Online meet and greet!
Moona-senpai is doing online meet and greet!
What?
Right?
Right.
But you know, also, just recently Moona-senpai released a new song called 100% and it's feat a certain Nerissa Waveron.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I really really liked it!
I'm sure there's lots of other songs on the album too!
So please check them out!
It's your chance, your chance to get your paws on all the samples' music!
Nerissa Ravencroft, I know, right?
It's that Nerissa Ravencroft with the... Mona.
Amazing.
BAU BAU!
So please check it out if you're interested, okay?
When?
You can check it out on the official hololive shop.
And the meet and greet is online.
That's all I know.
Where online?
I don't know.
That's just amazing.
So fun!
BAU BAU!
I really don't want to go online meet and greet.
Yeah... Oh, you're not a bit envious?
No... No... Wow... What a weird... Uh... I got in trouble... Not by like Mane-chan!
Not by Moco-chan!
That happens all the time!
Huh?
Um... I had a warning... Oh!
I had a warning with...
You know, FUWAMOCO, we've been going for walks.
Recently, you know, the weather's been nice.
What did you do?
So, we went for a walk.
You know.
And we're enjoying it.
And you know, we're just walking by and we're like, oh look!
There's a police officer over there!
You know.
Okay.
Well-protected streets.
Good, good, good.
And then there was one person that zoomed by on their bike and I was like, well that's quite an okay movement.
And then the police officer was like, Get off the bike!
Get off the bike!
In the nicest way possible, because that's dangerous!
Yeah, and I was like, yes.
We're like, yes, dangerous, thank you, good job.
That's what I thought too.
And then so we just keep on walking by like, good job, good job.
And then, couple meters down the lane, I hear
Close your phone!
Don't look at your phone and walk there miss!
Is that me?
I kind of had my phone open.
I wasn't looking at the phone screen!
I wasn't!
Okay!
But it was just open.
I was looking straight where I was walking.
Yeah.
I can understand.
Mococo wasn't in trouble.
I was framed, okay?
It wasn't me!
You were framed!
Who framed you, huh?
I just... I don't want to go back to the cell, you know?
Okay?
She doesn't want to go back in the cell.
I wasn't this time!
I did.
I was walking.
Yes.
It's not good to be on your phone.
It was just open.
I was looking at it.
I was looking at the phone.
Really?
That was close call.
I'm Muzai.
I'm innocent.
Muzai!
Fuwawa!
Ruffians, I'm innocent, right?
You agree with me, right?
Right?
I'm innocent?
You're not going to send me back to the cell, right, Ruffians?
Even if she is potentially a... What's the word?
Potentially... What?
Committed a crime looking at her phone while walking.
She sent me back to the cell!
You'll never catch me.
BAU BAU!
You should tell justice!
Please don't tell justice!
No justice needs to be elated!
It's okay!
BAU BAU!
Do you have something else to tell the Ruffians?
Ruffians, um, you have another secret?
I have a secret that I just decided not to tell you about for months.
It's kind of embarrassing, Moco-chan.
You know how, you know, you eat food.
When you have food, like a breakfast, or lunch, or dinner.
And then sometimes, um, there's some people that like to, you know, uh, maybe like try and be efficient.
And then like, uh, cook their food in the shower.
Like we're... Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
I might be kinda like that, Ruffians.
I don't- I don't rinse the fruits and the vegetables in the shower, okay?
But I do like to sleep in the bed.
With fruits.
At your door.
I have my banana, right?
Then I sleep in the bed with the banana pillow, right?
But recently, as in a while ago.
No!
I sleep in the bed with a banana and a tuna!
Yeah!
I sandwich between a banana and a tuna.
Basically that's FUWAMOCO's life.
Banana.
Tuna.
Fuwawa.
Yeah, you know, we're out having some fun with Biboo!
And you know, there was an arcade, so like, let's go with them!
And they have like, one machine where you know, there's like a plushie, a big plushie!
And it's stuck to a string, and you have to cut that string.
Well, there was a tuna on that line and I was like, okay, I'm just gonna do it.
What's in the mood for fishing?
Free twice, Ruffians!
I got it!
It's free twice!
Yeah.
No!
I don't want to take free twice!
Free twice!
Mokoko, give me 5,000 Yen!
Mokoko, give me 5,
Yeah.
No.
It was fast, but it wasn't that much fast.
So now, I guess officially, I like to sleep in bed with foot.
It's comfy!
I get a good sleep with my tuna and my banana.
I don't have anything.
Banana.
Tuna.
Fuwawa!
BAU BAU!
There's not too much space left.
Meow.
I'll find a little one.
I have space.
I think I could use something else in my bed too.
Huh?
I could use something else in my bed.
Like what, Moco-chan?
Something.
Comfy.
Tuk-tuk.
That's all.
Are you waiting for it to ship, maybe?
No?
Oh.
FUWAMOCO-chan, I'm feeling a little sad now because I was excited, but maybe you have something that can make me feel a little better?
Like, don't get a dare!
That makes me feel better, but not quite like that.
Ruffians.
Do you need a pup talk?
You need a pup talk?
Please?
It's okay.
You don't need to say pretty please.
Please is always good.
Okay?
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another well-needed FUWAMOCO Pup Talk!
And you're going to hear it straight from me, FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
Adventrix!
hololive fans!
Has it been a bit difficult recently?
I...want me to yell it.
Even feeling sad?
Even a bit despaired?
A bit lost?
I understand how you might be feeling right now, okay?
Fuwawa does too!
Please remember, okay?
It's okay to feel sad.
It's important to express those emotions, to talk to those around you, to those who care about you and will lend you their shoulder.
We know that it can be exhausting to feel such strong emotions and that it's hard to continue as you did and sometimes you feel like it might not be worth it for you to care about things like you did before.
And it's okay to take a break, to take a breather.
Please know that we'll always be here waiting for you.
And there will be more exciting, fun, and silly times ahead!
But we'll keep doing our best until we can see you again, okay?
We're here to protect your smile forever and ever!
And even though we know that it's pretty rough right now, that maybe your smile might be weakened, we hope that you know that we're here by your side, okay?
That we'll get through this together!
And, you know, our journey, it will always be smooth sailing, but even with its bumps, it's worth overcoming and growing together.
So, let's continue to do the best we can right now, Ruffians!
Whether that be being kind to yourself and giving yourself a lot of extra care, or continuing on without thinking too deeply into everything.
Okay?
Make sure to remember those around you too, who might be having a hard time.
And most of all,
You know, love those who mean a lot to you.
Lots and lots.
Okay?
Let's do our best to get through this!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at today's Doggie of the Day.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Kona!
And BAU BAU!
Cute!
With ears!
Look!
Look at this!
I go fluff on the nose there!
Wait, I go straight to the fluff nose!
Koda!
Do you not see it?
It's so silly!
Hi!
I know.
I feel like Kona's eyes, you can see just how wise she is.
Right?
So beautiful.
She looks like she can protect you well no matter how old or young she might be.
Yes!
So cute.
Very playful young.
Beautiful dog.
Distinguished lady.
That's what I was thinking too.
How did Kona BAU BAU Moco-chan?
I think...
Baobab!
Well, you know, we can tell.
I can see it in those eyes.
FUWANA is a very well-loved doggy.
And she's been adored for many years.
We're just glad that you make sure to cuddle her lots and lots.
Extra lots.
Give her scratches whenever you're able to visit her.
You know, there's a lot going on sometimes.
Maybe you can't see her as much as you want to.
But you know, it makes those times even more special the more love and
FUWAMOCO We got out on a walk.
Well, let's take a look at what you went on.
Today I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
Yeah!
Yeah, you see it!
The kongoyebi!
The sun going through the leaves, and they're going...
FUWAM
Wow, this is such a beautiful scene from Meiji Shrine.
Very famous.
But you know, I'm so happy to hear that you've been enjoying Japan together with your family.
Hopefully you saw some sakura.
Oh maybe, right.
But I hope that you're able to draw a good omikuji.
Yeah, good fortune.
If not...
Your luck starts now!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing a picture of your trip with us!
And let's see how our Question of the Day is!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
I wanted to ask what anime you like.
I have nothing to watch and I wanted to ask what anime you recommend.
BAU BAU!
Abyss, do you know what I'm going to recommend?
Do you?
Do you know what I'm going to recommend?
I have a feeling!
School days!
Yes.
You know, I recommend school days for a different feeling.
I'm not sure if that's the feeling you want to feel right now, but it's definitely a different feeling.
Maybe you'll feel feelings after you watch it.
Maybe it's a way to feel.
Can I raise a fang?
Something!
FUWAMOCO-chan, what are you going to recommend?
Odd Taxi is a good recommendation.
It's a good middle ground.
Go into it without anything.
Just being like, Odd Taxi, that's something.
Going with the open mind.
School days too, going with the open mind.
But they're both very different.
Is there any similarities between Odd Taxi and school days?
Modes of transportation.
Train and a taxi?
No, boat.
Taxi.
Oh, I guess it's also a pretty nice boat.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Okay.
Modes of transportation.
Road map.
But the art has helped us.
Please check them out!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much to our Ruffians for all the submissions today!
You know what?
FUWAMOCO Morning shall be made together with you, Ruffians!
Thank you for always being here in the mornings together with us.
And you know what?
If you happen to see Pero, even if FUWAMOCO might complain,
Please let us know.
If you see any cute doggies and you're like, oh this is my Doggie of the Day, I'm gonna share it with FUWAMOCO.
Please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
We're also looking for more of your vlogs, more of your questions.
I'm sure you have questions.
Please ask us with the hashtag.
BAU BAU!
For our next stream!
We have another stream coming up pretty soon here.
We're gonna be continuing Donkey Kong Country 2.
We've been playing it on the SNES.
Retro gaming.
Things are pretty crazy.
In case you are not familiar with our Donkey Kong streams.
We scream more than horror games.
You know Moco-chan plays, and I play.
I'm Dixie.
I'm Diddy.
A lot of things happen.
A lot of trouble is had.
Some swamming happens.
Controller goes through some abuse.
We might have almost got bled on the controller last time.
So who knows what's gonna happen this time, huh?
BAU BAU!
And for our schedule!
Our upcoming schedule like we shared earlier, Biboo's birthday is gonna be on Thursday at 6pm PT so we hope to see you there so we can all celebrate Biboo's birthday together!
And on Friday we'll be back with another episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we head off on our first mini vacation since our debut, we're gonna go around Japan, explore a little bit, you know,
We're gonna have a refreshing time, that's for sure.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU SMILE!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
YOKIA!
BAU BAU!
RIDORI!
I wish he said!
BOMBA!
Daniel Fair!
Rachel!
BOMBA!
Right!
Nexola!
BOMBA!
Vapor Blade!
Zombie!
BOMBA!
Junsu Sour!
Jaden Williams!
BOMBA!
Ashing!
BAU BAU!
Made-a-Pots!
Catchy!
BAU BAU!
Ride-A-Long!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!